yesterday a man in an anthropomorphic
cartoon bunny outfit appeared at the
White House lectern to greet reporters
many people were surprised by the
bunny's appearance
I was not
I know that Joe Biden has a reputation
as a moderate in the Democrat Party but
when it comes to weird sex stuff Biden
has always been ahead of the curve in
May of 2012 Joe Biden endorsed same-sex
marriage even when his boss Barack Obama
still opposed it in October of that same
Year Joe Biden went further and endorsed
transgenderism calling it The Civil
Rights fight of our time
and now in April of 2023 it would appear
that Joe Biden has endorsed furries
some of you are laughing I don't know
why
it is precisely as likely that a man
would become a cartoon rabbit as it is
that he would become a woman
you think
it's implausible that the president of
the United States would Embrace furrydom
huh did you ever think a president of
the United States would endorse chopping
off little kids genitals
no I am past thinking that things
couldn't ever go that far
especially when it comes to rabbits
because I know these days elementary
schools and libraries read kids gay porn
in the classroom but back in my day we
read books like Alice in Wonderland
and in Alice in Wonderland it's a rabbit
that leads Alice down the rabbit hole
into Wonderland
that is precisely
where our whole nation has been living
for a long time now I'm Michael
knowlesist Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show The Dalai Lama
asked a little kid to suck his tongue
we'll get to that very important news
story in just a little bit
first though I don't want it to seem
like I'm being too harsh on the
anthropomorphic bunny
I much prefer the bunny to Karine
Jean-Pierre if the bunny held the press
conference every single day that would
be a drastic improvement at the White
House unfortunately Kareem Jean-Pierre
did eventually come out
she came out to defend infanticide but
the Silver Lining to that storm cloud is
Kareem Jean-Pierre had a little a little
slip of the tongue that undermined some
of the other Biden Administration
priorities on the sexual culture War
Reproductive Rights is a fundamental
Freedom it is a fundamental right and it
is a medical decision that should be
made between a man a woman pardon me and
her doctor without government
interference again without government
interference abortion it's a serious
decision it should be made between a man
and his doctor oh no I mean so people
are pointing to this they're saying this
is a gaff from Korean Jean-Pierre there
is a gaffe in here but it wasn't that in
in Korean Champion's defense it's kind
of confusing these days sometimes
there's margin calls it's hard to tell
the difference between a man and a woman
the gaffe is not that Karine Jean-Pierre
said abortion is a decision between a
man and oops sorry
the the Gaff was that Korean Jean-Pierre
corrected herself at all
because I can't help but notice
the Corrine Jean Pierre and the White
House and the Liberals generally they're
pretty clear on what a woman is when it
comes to the issue of abortion
they just get a little tripped up when
it comes to other issues that are less
politically convenient for them
White House is inconsistent here I know
I don't think I'm nitpicking
the White House insists that
gender is totally different from sex and
men can become pregnant and women can
have phalluses and all the rest I mean
they say that with a straight face and
they're pushing the ideology from the
White House all the way down to
elementary schools they they say that
they believe that and then the moment
that it comes to their other preferred
issue abortion they say oh man men have
nothing to do with this men can't become
pregnant men can't have abortions it's
only women
so the White House is being inconsistent
here and of course the White House is
being inconsistent and of course
when they move on from the trans issue
in particular and they get to abortion
of course the White House goes back to
normal because everybody knows that
transgenderism is nonsense
that's why I'm excited at the prospect
of this debate that I'm scheduled to
engage in at the University of
Pittsburgh which has gotten a lot of
fanfare I think there was something like
12 000 signatures on a petition to ban
me from appearing on campus I said it
was kind of ironic because I'm scheduled
to be to debate a transgender
identifying scholar so if you cancel me
you cancel the transgender identifying
scholar but I'm excited at the prospect
of this debate because while I've
received plenty of debate requests from
two-bit Cloud chasing social media
influencer types I thought that that's
not going to do very much
the only way it's worth having this
debate is if it is with the person who
can give the best strongest most
credible argument for transgenderism
that there is and so this professor that
I'm scheduled to debate Professor Donald
now he goes by Deirdre McCloskey has
half a dozen honorary doctorates three
degrees from Harvard back from the day
when a Harvard degree sort of meant
something has dozens of academic
Publications I have no particularly
Advanced degree I am but a humble
podcaster I only have two books and only
one of them contains any words but
despite this David and Goliath kind of
matchup here
I I have the truth on my side we know
what a woman is we know what a man is we
know that men cannot really become women
and so I I wanna I wanna see the the
other side Steel Man their argument as
best as possible Professor McCloskey has
said that there's no reason to back down
from a debate he's actually opposed to
the people who want to shut down the
debate said the way to stop bad ideas is
with good ideas he said that this debate
quote unquote this will be very very
easy you know he's sort of disparaged
the idea that I could defend my position
that men and women are different so
anyway I think if the debate is gonna
happen at all on transgenderism you want
it to be with the absolute
top scholarly intellectual people who
can possibly defend it and I think you
could have four and five Harvard degrees
and you still wouldn't be able to defend
it in fact I think the more Harvard
degrees you've got probably the more
confused you get on that issue look at
Korean Jean Pierre not Korean Jean fear
rather look at uh judge katanji Jackson
the Supreme Court Justice who has asked
what is a woman and when she was asked
what is a woman she said well I don't
know I'm not a biologist
two Harvard degrees but but can't quite
tell so it's important to Hash that out
because even the Liberals admit they
know it's crazy when Kareem Jean-Pierre
is at the White House electron she
admits men cannot get abortions so okay
that's good have the debate
resolve it once and for all now speaking
of
taking care of yourself speaking of your
body
when you want to look good you got to
check out genucel right now go to
geniusell.com Knowles the day when
skincare was just for women are over are
you tired of dealing with puffy eye bags
dry skin and wrinkles do you want to
look and feel your best every day and
start taking your skincare routine
seriously and check out my friends over
at gen you sell skin care my producer
Ben Davies uses geniusell's Dark Spot
Corrector Mr Davies that guy can use all
the help he could get okay this is
formulated with revolutionary
ingredients that effectively diminish
the appearance of unsightly dark spots
acne scarring and any other patches of
discoloration some geniusell dark spot
corrector leaves Ben with a bright even
complexion definitely brighter and
evener than he started with he looks
younger healthier and more vibrant than
ever I love all of geniusell's products
but I particularly love their under eye
bag treatment say goodbye to Fine Lines
wrinkles and even those annoying under
eye bags geniuselle will have you
looking 5 10 or even 15 years younger
just in time for the normal weather
they guarantee results in as little as
12 hours for your money back try
geniusell's most popular package for 70
off at geniusell.com Knowles all orders
are upgraded to free shipping and every
subscription order includes a
complimentary spring spa box with three
spot Essentials three free gifts plus
free shipping go to geniusell.com
Knowles
and speaking of gender confusion
it's not just affecting kids and
teenagers
Mr Beast is probably the biggest YouTube
channel
his videos get tens of millions hundreds
of millions of views
Mr BEAST's sidekick
is a guy named Chris Tyson
sorry was a guy named Chris Tyson I
don't say that because he's dead I say
that because he says he's no longer a
guy
Chris Tyson is 26 years old
and he has just decided that he is
secretly a woman
Chris Tyson has made all sorts of jokes
about transvestites and transgenderism
and he's mocked the idea of it before
now
he says I am transgender I am a woman
all all fun and games right we kind of
giggle at it I I pity everyone who falls
into this
confusion
but this is even worse because Chris
Tyson is married and has a two and a
half year old child
and he just woke up one day told his
wife didn't tell his kid I assume
because the kid's probably just starting
to talk but told his wife yeah I'm
I'm not going to be your husband anymore
because I'm I'm going to be your wife or
something I'm a woman now
sorry Sonny I'm not Daddy anymore I'm
Mommy now or I'm something else but I'm
not Daddy whatever that is
and he's catching a lot of flack for
this online
now in response to that Chris Tyson has
said informed content
hormone replacement therapy saved my and
many others lives the hurdle gender
non-conforming people have to jump
through to get life-saving gender
affirming Health Care as a first world
in a first world country is wild to me
just let people make informed decisions
about their own bodies
in a first world country as if they have
these kinds of Therapies in non-first
world countries
they don't have a lot of these in Zambia
okay I don't think there's a lot of
hormone replacement therapy going on in
Namibia okay but
since this is absolutely shocking this
is life-saving treatment
this is the line they always use and
this is the line that the teachers and
the doctors use to guilt parents and and
initiate them into the transgender cult
is they'll say well would you rather
have a dead son or a living daughter
yeah you got a trans your kid you got a
trans your son and drop off his genitals
and put him put him into onto all these
hormones to make them look a little bit
more like a girl because if you know
he's going to kill himself and it's
going to be your fault it's a
life-saving treatment there is no
evidence of that there is no evidence
that the transgender transition
alleviates
anxiety depression suicidality although
to the contrary there is lots of
evidence that the transgender transition
exacerbates the sort of stresses and
despair that people are feeling
before they go into it we covered those
studies on the show last week
but furthermore put that aside for a
second with this guy
Chris Tyson
the problem here
highlights a broader problem within
liberalism within all of modern
political thought
which is we think about politics from
the perspective of what we can do it's
like Jurassic Park I know we can do this
stuff but did you ever think of you
should do this kind of stuff
we think of it from the perspective of
entitlements and we call those rights
even when they're they're things that
are manifestly wrong we still
preposterously call those wrong things
rights which is crazy because
wrongs cannot be rights it's right there
in the word writes regardless
it's not a good way to look at politics
a better way to look at politics a
better way to look at your own identity
is not from the perspective of Rights
and entitlement but from the perspective
of obligation not what you are owed but
what you owe to other people the reason
what this guy is doing publicly is wrong
is because he has an obligation to his
wife to be her husband
let's just say for a second that he
could change his sex and gender but he
can't but let's just say he could there
were some perfect surgery out there that
changed all of his DNA it changed all of
his features I mean that still wouldn't
change his Central identity but again
let's just let's just go for it he still
would have no right to do it
he took a vow to be her husband he has a
role he has a job to do he has a duty
and by neglecting that Duty he is
committing a grave Injustice against his
wife
then think about his kid
he owes it to his kid to be that kid's
father
that's his role that's his job that's
his duty
he doesn't have the right
to shirk that Duty
in pursuing his sexual fetish
he is denying his son
what his son is owed namely
a father
that's wrong and we we all do this
we don't we don't all go trans but but
we
all in Modern Life we we tend to shirk
our duties
we say oh who cares about my community
who cares about the common good oh who
cares about my family oh who cares and
we we make everything so cold and clean
and clinical and individualistic it's
not just the left that does that it's
the right that does that too
and you see this reflected in no fault
divorce
you see this reflected in the the
weakening of the American family even
between Generations
you see this in the below replacement
birth rate
you see this in the lack the the total
loss of of Civic
life and responsibility
we just forget our obligations
but we all have obligations
to our duty now I mentioned
that this guy just at age 26 when they
decided okay I'm gonna I'm gonna become
a woman
where does this come from
we talk about how well maybe it's just
this mental health condition called
gender dysphoria or we say well maybe
it's it's a true identity that they've
been just suppressing their whole lives
or we say well maybe now because it's
out there in the culture people are more
open-minded to it and they consider what
they previously hadn't even considered
which is a little more plausible than
the biological explanation but there's
one explanation that people aren't
really talking about
that I actually have to go to feminist
websites like the feminist current to
see anybody talking about which is
porn
according to
many writers
according to many people who have looked
into this who've looked into this a lot
more closely than I have porn is playing
a huge role in The Surge of
transgenderism we know that porn is
ubiquitous in the culture unless you are
actively pursuing a discipline not to
look at pornography and you are a man
chances are you are looking at
pornography in this culture porn rates
or among men are like over 90 percent or
something in the age at which young men
are exposed to this is
on average I think 11 and that's an
older statistic I think it's actually
declined since then
so feminist current writes why isn't
anyone talking about the influence of
porn on the trans trend in recent years
trans pornography has soared in
popularity according to pornhub's
metadata both trans and transgender porn
searches have more than quadrupled in
the three years between 2014 to 2017 and
by 2018 trans was ranked the fifth
highest search term of the year
now I was informed of this a few years
ago by a reporter colleague of mine here
at the daily wire who said Michael have
you heard about this kind of transgender
porn called hypnosis porn and I said
nope haven't heard about that one tell
me about it and she had gone on some
deep dive hadn't watched it but had had
read about it and
she said it's this kind of pornography
where when people fall into it it just
totally scrambles their brain more so
than even other kinds of pornography and
it can lead to a rapid onset feeling of
gender dysphoria
I said okay well uh I'm curious I don't
want to look up the porn for a couple
reasons one because that that would be
wrong to do and I don't want to expose
myself to that and I don't want to then
have to you know now I have to miss
lunch the next day so I can go to
confession you know it's just that's a
busy week so I didn't want to do that
but I did look through
forums of people talking about this and
articles in places like feminist current
and
the way people write about this genre of
porn is terrifying I remember I don't
remember the exact book but there was a
guy who said I fell into this porn in my
40s I was a totally normal guy I fell
into this genre of porn within something
like two years I couldn't get the idea
of becoming a woman out of my head it's
ruined my life another person said that
it seemed like a military-grade
psychological weapons I thought oh my
goodness I don't even when I'm reading
about this kind of porn I try to I don't
want too many details because it seems
like it's really really potent and it
would probably help to explain the
shocking surge in transgender identity
unless there's just something in the
water that's turning all the freaking
Zoomers trans not the frogs gay but the
Zoomer is trans then
probably there's something to do with
this if your view of sexuality is being
totally transformed and that phenomenon
is coinciding with everybody looking at
increasingly crazy pornography there
might be a connection there this is this
is what one person said in according to
the feminist current article quote I
started watching transporn initially
five or so years ago and I remember I
had post-orgasm regret so you know he
finished looking at the poor and doing
whatever he's going to do and then he he
felt uh shame at that which is a good
feeling to feel if you when you do
something bad but he says back then I
imagined myself as the guy about a year
and a half ago I started to imagine the
possibility of being the girl in these
scenarios I wanted to be
I'll clean up a little bit of the
language here I was turned on by the
submissiveness of it he says then he
goes on this has led me to have some
gender dysphoria as I would love to be
the woman and see where that would take
me in my life as a fully transition to
trans woman too long didn't read my
sexual and gender identity has been
completely flipped on its head because
of this hypnotism type porn
all of which is to say
the the White House has just declared
that the covid pandemic is over oh good
that's cool I'm glad I'm sure you can
all breathe a sigh of relief I know that
you were on the edge of your seats
worried staying up at night because you
were so worried about the covid pandemic
we were told for years that kovid was
the greatest Public Health crisis in the
country
porn is by far the biggest Public Health
crisis in the country and it's the one
that no one's allowed to talk about no
one who objects to it is allowed to
bring it up
and the ruling regime
pushes it on everybody the ruling regime
defends porn broadly on Free Speech
grounds which porn has never been
defended on Free Speech grants for the
whole history of our country until very
recently and the whole history of our
civilization until the river recently
it's obscene material obscenity is not
protected by Free Speech laws but
they're going further they're pushing
the porn in libraries and pushing the
porn in elementary schools it's a very
powerful tool to control people it's a
powerful tool to degrade people
when one looks at porn one has the
reaction that this guy has looking at a
very extreme and particularly degrading
form of porn but it's the same reaction
it's a kind of a shame
elsewhere in the feminist current
article someone said that the very Act
of looking
at pornography is degrading and so this
uh humiliating and hypnotic type of porn
is a kind of metapornography that it's a
pornography about
what it is to view pornography and it it
can take you to really really weird
places now I've tried to well I've tried
to speak in vager terms about this one
because mercifully I haven't seen it so
I can't really speak to the details but
two because I don't I don't want to Peak
anybody's curiosity this is powerful
powerful stuff according to pretty much
everyone who's come into contact with it
and everyone who's doing research on it
and
it would seem clear to me is leading to
lots of terrible effects on public
health and little little kids are being
exposed to it and we're just
dilly-dallying we're doing nothing about
that we're worried about covid oh no the
kid might catch a cough which
statistically won't do anything to him
what about that if you've got if you've
got something warping people's minds
that has the objective of degrading
people
and you degrade and humiliate a whole
people how are you supposed to have a
great country now when you want to edify
yourself when you want to educate
yourself you might want to check out
Grand Canyon University are you ready to
take the next step in your education but
struggling to fit traditional classes
into your busy schedule Grand Canyon
University's online programs are
designed to make earning your degree
easy and accessible no matter your age
or stage in life whether you're a busy
professional looking to advance your
career or a stay-at-home parent juggling
family responsibilities gcu's online
courses give you the flexibility you
need to learn on your own terms Grand
Canyon University specializes in helping
you fit your bachelor's Master's or
doctoral degree into your busy day from
scholarships to customized scheduling
your graduation team led by your own GCU
counselor provides you with the personal
support you need to succeed so why wait
if you're ready to take your education
to the next level you need Grand Canyon
University find your purpose at Grand
Canyon University one of my favorite
schools I've ever visited I've got some
colleagues actually who I met visiting
Grand Canyon University now they work
with us
gcu.edu that is
gcu.edu if you're looking for something
interesting to watch check out our
series what we saw hosted by Storyteller
Bill Whittle season one is focused on
Apollo 11 and right now for a limited
time all four episodes are available for
free on YouTube meanwhile on daily wire
plus season two of what we saw is in
full swing and this time bill has set
his sights on the Cold War and the
tension between two superpowers that
lasted for 45 years episode 5 picks up
with the death of Joseph Stalin as a
newly inaugurated President Eisenhower
has just taken office with Knives Out
for succession in the USSR Eisenhower
sees this moment as a brief window of
opportunity to reset the conflict Bill
makes you feel like you're there
witnessing history
new episodes of Cold War come out every
week but you've got to be a member to
see it go to dailywire.com Cold War to
start watching also this past weekend
yes or no the greatest interview show on
the internet came back with a new
episode I sat down with the youngest
member of the daily wire family and my
Jeremy's chocolate counterpart Brett
Cooper we bridge to the generational Gap
this episode so you're not going to want
to miss it you also shouldn't miss your
chance to bring the fun home and order
yes or no the game right to your door
that's right the pre-order is over and
yes or no is in stock at dailywire.com
shop we are actively shipping games once
more but do not wait they just sent out
a lot of the pre-orders and it took out
most of the stock that we've got right
now so I would strongly recommend if you
do want a copy that you get it now last
time we did this it sold out instantly
so order your copy and secure it today
daily wire.com
shop
so
there's a story that I want to get to
before we get to the Dalai Lama sucking
on a or trying to suck on a boy's tongue
which you know let's let's have a
palette cleanser between all the weird
sex stuff there is
a big threat to journalists right now a
big threat even to my job but because I
consider myself
working as a journalist but not of the
journalist class because I think that
the establishment media the mainstream
media are effectively the enemy of the
people I'm celebrating this even though
it threatens my own employment Kuwait
has just rolled out
a virtual
news anchor her name is
artificial intelligence equate news what
kind of news do you prefer let's hear
your opinions
very nice looking blonde woman very
pretty but not too pretty so you're
still you're still hearing the news from
her
fed hot is an old Kuwaiti name it refers
to Silver and I think the reason they
name for that is because we imagine
robots to be metallic kind of like you
know on The Jetsons or something like
that and she is not though she looks
like a person if you just watched her
read the news you would think this is a
real person but this is not a real
person and so a lot of people especially
conservatives are going to hear this
story
which is not being reported in a lot of
places it's even hard to track down the
video because it's in Arabic they're
going to see the story and they're going
to say oh I will I'll never watch that
I'm not going to get my news from a
robot you're not going to trick me
you will
you will get your news from a robot at
some point
and
you will engage with this technology
sooner than you think
it'll just be everywhere
you already probably get a fair bit of
your news from robots because robots
have just invaded Twitter
and a lot of the trends that you see are
because Bots are are pushing those
Trends up
there is a benefit here it's not all
just dystopian
the benefit of artificial intelligence
is one that it's kind of cool and you
can see interesting artwork on some of
the programs and it's it is a
technologically impressive thing that
you've got this fake woman who can read
you the news you can have her say
anything and it'll it'll seem
indistinguishable from a real person but
what I like about AI what I think the
Silver Lining is here
is that it highlights what it means to
be human you're going to get your news
from AI because the AI is going to know
the news better than the people do
you're going to get your news from AI
because that is going to be the way that
that news organizations start to push
the news out maybe not in the form of
this car this this artificially
generated fake woman
but AI is going to do that and it's
going to do it better and faster and
more accurately than human beings and so
you will engage with it
it shows us what it means to be human
because it shows us that limitations are
at the very Heart Of Being Human and if
you lose the limitations you lose your
Humanity and this is what not you you
see especially in the transgender
movement but but this is what the whole
project of political liberalism has
shown us the whole project of political
liberalism is to break past
the traditional limits and boundaries of
what it what it means to be human
liberate ourselves from a political
order and from the nation and from our
families and from even our biological
selves and we're going to break those
limits but when you break all the limits
then you're gone
because you are human you're finite you
exist within limits if you break all the
the limits all you've done effectively
is kill yourself you've annihilated
yourself
so what does it mean
you might think well look I get my
identity because I'm the best
artist
well pretty soon AI if not already AI is
going to make
better art than you we'll make the same
art that you can so you still have a
role in making art but it'll make very
very impressive art you will not be the
best artist
well I get my identity because I'm the
best news presenter no you're not
you there the robots will be better news
presenters than you are well I get my
identity because I'm the best accountant
no you're not the best account in the
world the robots are going to be way
better accountants than you for sure
well I'm I'm the best this I'm the best
at no
your identity has to come from something
more real and we we try to ground our
identity in all of these glittering
Idols in our professions where we try to
ground our identity in our Hobbies or
our increasingly in consumer culture we
ground our identity in the our products
that we consume or you grant your
identity in some sexual fetish or desire
that you have you see that a lot these
days your identity's got to be
grounded in something more real your the
true place that your identity must be
grounded
is in God because God is the source and
Summit of being and all identity
and then you can have your profession
and then you can have your family and
then you can have your community and
then you can have your affinity for
certain products we all do that's part
of a normal life but it's in its proper
place
and you fulfill your roles as we were
talking about earlier with the Mr Beast
guy
you'll fulfill your roles you do your
jobs you fulfill your obligations but
you do all of that because of where your
identity is ultimately grounded you will
not be the best
at all of these secondary things for
much longer as AI
advances at lightning speed we went from
AI could do blurry kind of weird demon
looking images where the hands were all
messed up to AI can create a human being
who speaks and looks perfect reading the
news in like six months it's going to
move very very fast
speaking of spiritual matters I've got
to get to the Dalai Lama
this is video I'm sure you've seen the
video the Dalai Lama is at some event
and he talks to a young boy and the
young boy comes up and gives a Dalai
Lama a hug and then the Dalai Lama asks
well I'll let you hear it in his own
words
[Laughter]
then I think here also yeah Sonny gives
the boy a little kiss kiss on the lips
and the audience is sort of laughing and
laughing
put their heads together
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
puts his hand on his face I don't know
it's kind of weird it's pretty weird man
I'm not
I don't know people are reading this and
saying that Dalai Lama is a secret pedo
child molester I don't know if he were
that wouldn't you expect him to do this
kind of thing in private
I doubt the fact that he's doing it out
in public makes me think this is
probably more likely just a kind of a
weird joke from a guy who's 87 years old
now I I don't know I mean it's
it's really really odd but one thing
it's doing regard regardless of what it
is I'm not really here to knock the
Dalai Lama and it's all out on tape you
can form your own conclusion is
it it
it dispels some of the
myth around the Dalai Lama a lot of
people in the west are fascinated by the
Dalai Lama because a lot of people in
the west are fascinated by Eastern
religion because a lot of people in the
west have abandoned their own religion
and so they they've been disenchanted
with their own religion but because we
have a natural spiritual longing we're
looking for something so we've been told
since kindergarten Christianity is fake
the Bible's bunk it's a Sciences what
you should follow and science totally
disproves God or whatever nonsense they
tell you but so we've been disenchanted
there but we're looking for something
else so people look to Hinduism we think
about George Harrison was fascinated by
Hinduism or a lot of a lot of suburban
white women just love Buddhism they just
they're so they don't really know that
much about it but they're drawn to it
and they go do yoga and it's essentially
the substitute for for their church on
Sunday and for their own religious life
in Christianity
and then you look at the Dalai Lama
doing this and you're saying wait huh
this guy that doesn't seem so mystical
and pure and wonderful and it's a
reminder too that the Dalai Lama is
primarily a political figure obviously
has a huge religious aspect to it as
well because all states at all times
have had something to do with religion
because all human conflict ultimately is
theological but he's a political leader
the institution of The Dalai Lama is
less than 500 years old it's a
relatively modern
position and the Dalai Lama is the
leader of Tibet
that's and all of the spiritual uh
trappings of that are from a practical
standpoint in service of his standing as
the leader of Tibet and and his role as
a politician is emphasized by his take
on religion which is Dalai Lama doesn't
encourage people to convert to Buddhism
in fact what he said is he encourages
people to remain in the religion of
their own communities
Christianity uniquely is Universalist
Go Make Disciples of all Nations
most other religions are more local
the Jews don't evangelize
the Buddhists don't really evangelize
the Hindus don't evangelize their their
social structures from within their own
tribe and from within their own Nation
and the fascination with the Dalai Lama
and the Dalai Lama's Insight on politics
should remind us of that there's no
escaping religion
in your life and there's especially no
escaping religion in politics politics
religion rather forms the basis of
politics so which religion is it going
to be
it's gonna be Buddhism we're gonna live
in a Buddhist Nation
you know is America going to become a
Hindu Nation
I don't think so I think it's probably
going to be a Christian Nation so what
what does that tell us about the way
that we ought to live and structure our
politics wait you know when we got to
talk to each other about this kind of
thing when you want to talk you got to
check out pure talk right now go to
puretalk.com use promo code Knowles we
all know about the big wireless
companies out there they lock you into
these horrendous contracts and if you
try to get out of them what happens they
tack on outrageous charges that is one
of the big reasons why I made the switch
to Pure Talk where there are no hidden
fees no contracts and no hassle pure
talks U.S customer service team helped
me make that switch in as little as 10
minutes and I was even able to keep
whatever phone number I wanted if you
want a new phone number you can get that
if you want a new phone you can get that
pure talk just makes it all so easy Pure
Talk has a range of affordable plans to
choose from you can find the perfect
option for your needs unlimited talk
text plenty of data for just thirty
dollars a month their 5G service is
super fast consistent does not drop
calls you can get the same coverage
you're used to same networks at half the
rate your current paying pure truck
saves the average family over 900 per
year go to puretalk.com enter promo code
Knowles to save fifty five zero percent
off your first month purechalk.com promo
code Knowles Pure Talk is simply smarter
Wireless
my favorite comment yesterday is from JB
amazing100 who says the release date of
the Mario movie April 5th should
officially be known as the Italian day
of visibility I agree maybe the Italian
day of vengeance
all right
I want these people who are
discriminating against the Italians
I want their political power dead
I want their ideology dead
I want that house burned to the ground I
want to go over the ground Office of the
ashes
sorry I don't know what happened I was
possessed by the
by the the Italians of my ancestry in in
ages before
it is a day of disability it's great and
John leg was almost very upset about
that speaking of Nations and how Nations
get along with each other
are we
in World War III
are we there now
Mike Pompeo looks as though he's going
to run for president former Secretary of
State for Donald Trump former CIA
director also for Trump
Mike Pompeo has just come out
unlike a lot of the rest of the GOP
field he has come out in defense of a
robust
interventionist American foreign policy
so a lot of people aren't going to like
it but it will give people a choice and
and Pompeo is sticking by his
convictions here
Pompeo says that with China aggressing
over Taiwan in the South China Sea and
the United States Navy now meeting some
of that progression and standing firm in
the South China Sea
and with the debacle in Ukraine and with
the debacle in Afghanistan now
emboldening China to say okay we don't
know if Joe Biden is going to get
reelected but he's weak so if we're
going to move we got to move now
especially because Biden has been
particularly weak on China for 20 years
20 plus years
tensions seemed to be ratcheting up and
a Chinese invasion of Taiwan
could be the last straw to to prompt
World War III we've already got the war
in Europe based around Ukraine if you
get a war in the Pacific you have a
World War and it's between all the same
Powers that's called a World War and so
Pompeo says
the way to stop this
is to spare no resource in defending
Taiwan including the use of American
troops I know the Taiwanese foreign
minister who you played the clip from
earlier he's precisely right there could
be an accident there that could escalate
pretty quickly the task for the United
States is to protect the things that
matter to Americans and make no mistake
about it uh the the business and
industry that sit on the island of
Taiwan which should be recognized as a
Sovereign Nation is essential to
American Commerce we need to make sure
that we're doing everything we can to
provide Taiwan with the tools its needs
contrast that with what the
administration has done in Ukraine where
they've allowed this war to linger on
are you on board with that as well U.S
troops on the ground to defend Taiwan
Sandra we often talk about Taiwan in
isolation think about this Japan will
almost certainly get drawn into this if
there's an invasion of Taiwan we have a
security guarantee to support Taiwan
much like Article 5 in the NATO
agreement what we need to do is focus
today on giving the Taiwanese the tools
they need to make sure that this day
never happens that's what we did for
four years and we reduced risk to
America but when push comes to shove the
United States is going to have to be all
in to protect American interests
throughout the Pacific
so there he is and this is a
pretty standard Republican position it's
gotten a little complicated in recent
years but the position is we don't want
to go to war
we Republicans are less inclined to go
to war than the Democrats are and
therefore in order to prevent War we are
going to threaten War more than the
Democrats will the argument is Reagan
said it peace through strength
and what the Democrats do is they seem
very weak and that weakness invites
aggression and you see that happen in
Ukraine Joe Biden said we're going to
take the sanctions off of Russia and by
the way Russia if you invade Ukraine if
it's only a minor incursion we're going
to let that slide and so what happens
Russian invades that America feels the
obligation to go in that won't just give
Ukraine up to to Russia and so
there's a schizophrenic foreign policy
and the conflict escalates
Wars have started I'm not making any
point over what Pompeo is saying I'm
just pointing out
Wars have started over a lot less major
Wars world wars have started over a lot
less than what's going on in Ukraine and
what's going on in Taiwan right now
Could Happen very very quickly and how
will we even know about it what can we
even believe when the media
are so dishonest
we know that the Chinese media are
dishonest that's propaganda that's State
media
we know the Russian media is dishonest
it's state media it's propaganda
we know that the same is true of our
media and our news outlets even though
we don't want to admit that this is why
I love what Elon just did on Twitter
Elon just branded NPR state-sponsored
media
he does do Iran and Russia North Korea
he says this is state-sponsored Media
now he backed down a little bit because
because now it says it is a government
funded media so not totally
state-sponsored
uh but the point Remains the Same
people were shocked by this why are you
shocked it's called National Public
Radio
shocked when we would do this to PBS
it's called Public Broadcasting
why can't we call it state-sponsored
media
oh because it's only state-sponsored
media when the bad guys do it when we do
it it's great the BBC is not
state-sponsored media no no no
Elon actually
responded when the BBC objected to being
called state-sponsored media
Elon said uh remind me what does BBC
stand for again is it the British
broadcast yes sort of what I thought it
was
political Concepts
are much more Universal than we want to
admit
and this is where I think a little bit
of the disconnect comes in with
Americans looking around at the rest of
the world
we pride ourselves on being the best
country on Earth and
when we've got good leadership we are
the best country on Earth
we've got bad leadership things can go
very very wrong but yeah we've got good
leadership people are doing the right
thing we are the best country on Earth
but we're not totally different from
other countries
we have this idea
that other countries do all of these
terrible things and we would never do
those things because we're fundamentally
different countries
in the way that we conduct politics that
isn't true China do you know China as a
social credit score in China
if you contradict the ruling regime you
can be
silenced you can be prosecuted and
investigated you can be told that you
can't board airplanes you can be
debanked and kicked out of financial
institutions you can be
removed from the economy you can
all of those things happen here
maybe not as at the scale that you see
them in China but all those things
happen here
and do you know in in China if you
oppose the regime they'll throw you in
prison
and they'll do it on trumped-up charges
oh you don't say Oh yeah talk to the
grannies from January 6th do you think
well well the gangsters from BLM who
looted and rideed and pillaged and
burned while they just go free the DA's
let him off the hook the grannies who
went in and took a picture in the
capital they're rotting in solitary but
you want to tell me about Prosecuting
political dissidents
well China surveils the population
that's right they've got cameras and
data collection and surveillance
everywhere interesting tell me about a
little branch of the government
formerly known as the No Such agency you
ever hear about that the NSA you really
want to lecture China about data
collection no
we
engage in these things and I'm not even
knocking the United States for doing it
the the concepts that that form
political life and the practices that
form political life are going to be
basically Universal because nations are
relatively similar
the implementation
and how they're particularly implemented
that's what's going to be different
the the
spirit that animates a people that's
going to be a little bit different
that's why ultimately it's the religion
that animates a people and our moral
understandings in the way that we're
going to limit what we do that's going
to be
different but that's where the
difference lies it doesn't lie in these
fundamental political practices those
are common to pretty much everybody now
speaking of the state
Joe Biden
has actually subverted expectations he's
one of the most predictable
shallow empty suited politicians out
there but he is defying one big
expectation which is all the smart
people said for years now Joe Biden's
not going to run for a second term Joe
Biden can't run for a say it's
ridiculous he's not going to run
here's Joe Biden on Easter Sunday
plan on
three or four more Easter egg rolls at
least three or four maybe five maybe
five maybe six what the hell are you
saying that uh that you would be uh
taking part in uh our upcoming election
you know being the you know the guy
who's pushed them out come on help a
brother out
I plan on running now but we're not
prepared to announce it yet
I think he means it Joe Biden is rarely
sincere about anything in his whole life
but I think he means it
why would he
why would he quit
because it's good for the Democratic
party what is Joe Biden care Joe Biden's
a thousand years old he doesn't he
doesn't stand to benefit from serving
the parties he served his party for 50
years at the federal level
he wants to be president this guy has
wanted to be president since he was in
the womb it's the object that he is
doggedly pursued his whole life why
would he give it up if he can still
stand and speak which he sort of can do
right now
I don't see why he wouldn't and by the
way I'm not sure that it's good for the
Democratic party for him not to run it
shows that the the
ship is unstable if the leader steps off
shows that things aren't totally ready
to go it's an admission that things
aren't going great
and who's going to come fill it in Liz
Warren everyone hates her Pete bootage
give me a break Kamala Harris yeah okay
Gavin Newsom maybe but he's he's totally
untested and the Democrat has never won
the White House from California last
person to win the White House from
California was Ronald Reagan politics
looked a lot different back then I think
he means it
so you might very likely have another
match off between Trump
and Biden
though there is some interesting polling
on the Republican primary race coming
out of Florida now
I'll leave you on that Cliffhanger we'll
have to get to that tomorrow because
we're about to enter
the membrane segmentum the member block
here baby the rest of the show continues
now you do not want to miss it I think
I'm a member use code noleskin wlas
check out for two months free
on all annual plans daily word.com
Knowles see you there
[Music]